Hello, my name is Camil.
I am doing the task of recording Goose sighting
with a slug of u
um, UOCI dash ROC
dash 14.
I believe that's correct, yes. Uh, UOI. Yes, sorry.
Um, and uh, again, my name is Camille
and uh, pretty much I'm doing the task of,
uh, just going through a quiz
and, uh, editing an answer, uh,
on a type of goose when I get toward the end.
And of course, in the meantime, uh, describing
what issues I have.
And speaking of accessibility,
I will be using an onscreen keyboard for navigation
along with the occasional usage of a magnifier lens
to see the webpage easier.
And those are my two accessibility
features on a Windows 11 desktop.
So let's get started.
I'm gonna minimize my little cheat sheet here.
So there we go. I'm on your page
and we're supposed to click on start now.
So I'm gonna tab over to it
and, sorry, forgot.
Focus on the page. Okay, let's try again.
So we're gonna tab over and it says skip to main content.
So if I press enter, I'm not sure where it went. Okay.
Ah, there it is. Okay.
So somehow skip to main content.
Oh, I see. Okay. Yeah, I should have pressed, uh,
I guess enter to skip to main contest at that point.
I dunno where the focus is,
but if I press tab once, uh,
this focus goes on the store now button, which is great,
also great is that the, uh, there's no
fancy border, it just literally turns it in.
The green start now button turns into a yellow button
where when I am un focus.
So that is absolutely awesome and great.
Uh, you, you know, it's a color change for me.
That's perfect. I don't have to, I don't have
to really look hard to see
where I am focus wise, so, perfect.
Uh, I'm gonna press enter and there we go.
We start the quiz again.
We're gonna tab, uh, skip
to main content.
I'm gonna press enter, not exactly sure
where it goes the first time,
but if I press tab again, uh,
that might be a little more on my end, I'm not sure,
but it does tap over Perfect.
To the, uh, radio buttons to choose yes
or no, uh, if I click left or right.
Perfect. Uh, not only are they automatically
filled in, should we say,
but you can choose between, uh, yes or no.
So we're gonna tab over one more time
and actually tabs to the top of the page, which is not
what I expected, but let's see.
I might be just error on my part.
Let's see if I press down,
I am just going in between yes or no.
If I do left or right, I'm doing between yes or no.
So right now the only tiny issue is I have
to find a way to get to the continue button.
So let's see if I tab, it goes to the top of a browser.
So I'm gonna just tab through
and I am not finding
a way to reach
at least what I can see
that the continue button.
I'm gonna try it one more time.
I'm on the skip to main content.
I'm gonna press enter, I'm gonna press tab ones
and we are on the questions again.
Uh, I can choose the question up, down, left,
right, doesn't matter.
But I am not seeing a way right now to get over
to the continue button.
Uh, let me move the zoom out
of the way just in case for something else.
I honestly don't see anything else.
Uh, I'm gonna try one more time.
Maybe I'm missing something. It doesn't look right. Good.
I'm gonna skip. Yeah, so, uh, right now we have a big,
giant problem with, uh, keyboard navigation
because I can find a way to get over
to the continue button.
I can choose the answer again,
highlights in yellow, no problems there,
but I have no way of
getting over to the continue button.
And I tried every, uh,
keyboard command when I know.
So that's a major problem.
Uh, thankfully I can't use a mouse,
but again, for pure keyboard navigation, uh,
definitely needs to be fixed.
So we're gonna press, I'm gonna click on continue.
Ironically, when I did click, it did change to yellow, so
that's interesting.
Something I noticed. That's interesting
because I would've thought they would've just kept
being green on y yellow.
So maybe there is a way, I don't know
what fight on this question on, uh, what type
of groups did I see?
Fill in a blank. So I'm gonna tab over to it again.
Skip for main content.
Yes, tab over once,
took a few tabs,
but see if I tab backwards.
Yeah, so, um, skip to main content feels like there's, uh,
you have to tab twice to actually get to where you go,
but that's not minor, that's minor compared to the,
you know, on the previous question
where I couldn't get to the continue button.
So right now I'm in the, uh, um, I'm in the section
where you type in your answer, uh, again in lighted yellow
so I know exactly where I am.
Super I'm at because, uh,
even though it's a white background, ERO is distinct
and I don't have to guess where I am in focus.
So we're gonna type in a goose.
I'm gonna type in a
great goose and whoops, sorry.
All right. And I do, I think I lost focus.
Nope, sorry, that's my error. Sorry.
Um, focus is still good.
I might be misspelling the type of goose,
but that really doesn't count for this task.
So I typed in the goose
and let's see if I can get over to the continue button
with just the keyboard.
And this time I did, which is strange.
So it seems like the problem
so far was just question number one.
Question number two did go where it needs to go, but,
but continue button tone yet.
So that's where I'm assuming the focus is.
And if I press enter, perfect, we go to the next question.
So, so far question one had the issue of,
uh, reaching continue with keyboard navigation.
Question two was fine.
So that's strange and disappointing
because if, if I only had onscreen keyboard
and no way of using a mouse, I would've been very,
uh, up
Upset would be the word or frustrated,
but I couldn't do the rest of your goose questions.
But anyway, we are successfully at number three
with keyboard navigation.
So when did you see a goose, for example?
Uh, they give you an example.
So we have to do day, month,
and year, which is of course the European standard.
So once again, we're gonna tab, try to tab over there,
skip the main content, press enter tab one
perfect day is highlighted.
Again, it's a fill in the blank.
Uh, wise, I'm totally fine with focus.
Where I am, I can see fine.
So with the keyboard, we're gonna type in the day
and we're gonna, I'm gonna press the right arrow key
to see if I can move over.
I'm assuming not. Yeah, I didn't think so. So sorry.
Uh, that was just my testing. So, uh, tab was over to month.
We're gonna pick a month tab one over to a year,
and we're gonna choose 2007.
So, uh, we're gonna tab over one more time
and I'm expecting it to get to continue hopefully.
And yeah, this one does seem to get to continue
with having any difficulties.
So once again, just question one was the odd ball out.
So, uh, I'm on continue 'cause it turned yellow.
I'm pressing enter. And boom, we get to the end.
Now I remember we were supposed to change the type of goose.
So, uh, we're gonna try to tab over to the, uh,
world where it says change.
I'm on skip domain contest, press enter
tab one more go down to change.
Uh, the first change is highlighted, meaning for, uh,
question one I just raised,
I picked no for question one.
I wonder if that has anything to do with it,
but that's not the point in focus right now.
So we're gonna tab over one more time.
So I'm as, um, assuming it will go down to the
change on the second question.
It does perfect. So I'm gonna press, uh,
actually I'm gonna press enter.
We are highlighted on change again, clearly visible,
even whether it's in white background,
but a plus fair, uh, pressing enter,
boom, breaks me back.
Second question. Great again, uh, tabs to main content
enter tab one more.
Hmm, sorry. So, uh, oh, excuse me, we get
to the fill in the blank.
I have to admit, just a little personal pet peeve.
I wish the, almost the previous answer was there, uh,
because if, uh, yeah, if somehow I'd forgotten
what was my previous answer,
I might retype in the same answer.
But again, that's a personal pee.
Um, so again, highlighted on the fill in the blank,
uh, again, you focus.
Perfect. We know we are.
So I'm gonna type in a different type of goose.
I don't know much about geese, so
hopefully I'm correct
on that.
Actually, I'm gonna change my mind.
I type in this, uh, a blue goose.
Yes, I know it may not exist,
but that's not the concept of this task.
Again, ta uh, I'm sorry, typing it in seems fine,
just like the first time
around I did this specific question.
So we're going to tab one perfect
and continue is highlighted.
Press enter and we actually go to the second question, which
I would've preferred to have a way
to skip past the question.
I went to go back straight to the summary,
but it is what it is.
I mean, it does work.
Um, so I mean that would be a preference,
but I do understand once you go to change, it will just,
you'll have to go through the questions
no matter which number you want it to edit.
But I'm gonna pick at my time sheet,
or I'm sorry at my cheat sheet to see
if there was anything else
you did need a submit application.
Okay, so, uh, I guess I'm filling in the
third question again for day, month, and year.
Truthfully, I don't remember exactly what I chose.
Maybe I do, let's see.
I have a feeling it's gonna be a little different than
what I wrote in the first time,
but I could be only off by a little bit.
Anyway, I sound gonna press stab once again.
Go to continue highlighted. Perfect.
We get back to the summary page.
I'm moving on my onscreen keyboard to get out of,
to see if there's a submit.
Uh, the best of your knowledge,
what happens to my data.
Uh, there a continue button, which
is not exactly the same as a sub submit button to me,
but, uh, that's what I'm gonna go for.
Let's see if I can tab over to it.
Uh, of course I am on change, change
and change for a third question.
So one more tab should actually get me over to
what happens with my data or data.
So I'm thinking two tabs
and I should be on the word continue.
Let's see, once, twice. Perfect.
I presenter on continue. And there we go.
I assume that would finish the task.
So with a nice little ose.
Uh, so right now in uh, summary,
that accessibility part of reaching, uh,
the website was great.
The focus was awesome.
I could tell Zachary where I was on what highlighted item.
The only major disappointment was with just
question one, not being able to reach
that continued button with the keyboard.
I think it's most puzzling to me,
but it was just question one and two
and three were absolutely fine.
The rest of the website worked fine with focus
and just general usage.
So yeah, the big, the big problem needs
to be looked at is question number one of not being able to,
at least I couldn't reach the continued button
with pure keyboard navigation.
Otherwise, yeah, everything looked good.
Just let again, we are, you know,
just question one.
I would expect it not to work on other questions,
but other questions we're fine.
So that's the big issue it needs to get fixed.
Again, thank you so much for letting me test your website.